[Applause]
okay here are the questions Paul Begala
do the Democrats have an effective
strategy to combat gerrymandering yes
well they're working on Eric Holder the
former attorney general yes is leading a
movement to do that at President Obama
with Obama helped us support it and fund
it there's no two better people but
we've got it do it I mean by the way if
we want to tear down monuments to
slavery segregation let's start with
denying the vote to African Americans
which states across America had done
[Applause]
also have to work on a be careful of is
while this is all happening in a
longer-term plan Trump's team is making
a play to undermine the census and
defund the Census Bureau so there will
not be able to count and accurately
represent who is in the country live
here this one I didn't know but every
time I think he's nanny exhausted he'll
compromise and count him as three-fifths
though but that's illegal immigrants
won't take this census because they're
afraid of a knock on the door in a way
that they weren't as much last time we
had a census so if they're going to be
they're going to be under counted
they've been granted in the past because
they've had the implicit they were
afraid the apocrypha of all those who
are ashamed embarrassed by Trump's
charlottesville statements along human
affairs in fact using shifting
government funds for violence by by
white supremacist dan time for
interaction yeah they're not ashamed of
his appointing Jefferson Barbara Davis
so I I suspect that come no no come
September because the gender will be
intact that's that's what strange he's
legitimate still be intact after all
this madness
mmm Frank what explains why some parts
of the country remain so backward when
it comes to gay rights isn't even true
anymore yeah it is the numbers are over
fifty percent nationally that they
support gay marriage yeah well this is
only going one way long-term because if
you look at the polls it's generational
more than anything else
so even if you pull evangelical
Christians under the age of 30 more of
them support gay marriage than not but
in the south and in some other regions
the church still holds great sway and a
lot of this really does boil down to
that you're right it is it yeah it is a
church thing look at me attacking a
church next to a Reverend Jesse Jackson
our voter ID laws the new Jim Crow it's
positive though Jim Crow the scheme's
actually the idea of voter fraud is a
fraud yeah for 77,000 builders they're
not rich at the top of the ticket which
means it was a manky thing you know the
very first the first paragraph in the
New York Times editorial on northern 9th
is the Republican chairman celebrating
the fact you suppress a black man that's
an increase of about 21 percent because
of voter suppression so those who've not
the rent was not in fact use purging as
a weapon okay what do you what does the
panel think about the rumored Kasich
Hickenlooper unity ticket to challenge
Trump in 2020 wait a second Kasich
Hickenlooper is Democrat and no III mean
lawrence O'Donnell as I was saying that
Paul Ryan is actively challenging and
because he went to Seattle or something
in made a speech you think III don't
know I I don't think any Republican is
going to unseat Trump from the
nomination in 2020 Kasich will run I
think really again I mean he's been
making all the noises for it really like
John Kasich go compared to trump
absolutely no there's that no John
Kasich is like he's has a very curved
Lindsey Graham ish record when it comes
to just constantly favoring
interventions around the entire globe in
ways that the media doesn't really give
him guff for you know that this crazy
false equivalency living here on this
panel every [ __ ] week from people who
who pick apart little things that you
know I don't like any of these guys
either I don't like Kasich I never like
boy
Mitt Romney and all these [ __ ] people
it's not the same as this demented
manchild in full makeup they're the same
I'm saying that a lot of people have a
soft spot in their heart for Kasich
because they haven't actually looked at
what he's done either as governor or as
a candidate I have a soft spot for
normalcy and sanity and somebody who's
not gonna blow up the world it's what I
okay does the panel think Trump will
scrap NAFTA if it's stupid I'm sure he
will next question
scrapped NAFTA anybody anybody want to
bite on that one he will he pawned
himself I think there's no line he would
if he could not going to fire molar he's
going to pardon us I said this earlier
the pie oh pardon was awful in and of
itself but I also think it was a signal
to the targets of the Moller
investigation that I got you back I
think he I think there's no line I think
your editorials great tonight there's no
line he won't cross got it write it down
if it was not written down he'll do it
or you have businesses go to him and
make something happen or the generals
write somebody else has to weigh in for
him to say okay I don't care enough
about this to argue with you I'll let
you deal with it whether it's the
Afghanistan war for the general or NAFTA
and businesses McConnell and must write
must write it now they cannot say he's a
bad guy cause he is unkind and then no
embraces agenda like they did they kind
of wrote a little law that said you
can't fire more right they haven't
passed it though right right one of the
guys who wrote it Tom Tillis got a call
from President Trump I'm sure reaming
him out about oh yeah this is that they
do they've all put their spines in a
blind trust as Republicans on the hill
and I would pick another body part 14 my
mom left
but it's a clean show my mama but
another Russian ambassador turned up
dead today yeah like it happens all the
time
and it doesn't seem to be natural causes
and I'm sure every time it does Trump
goes geez I wish I could do that but
again we'd all Riley asked him about
that he said Putin's a killer so do you
think we're so great exactly I do you
think we're so great and I guess who's
so evil like my president to be able to
say that yeah thank you everybody thank
you
[Applause]